chadwick boseman the actor best known
for playing black panther in the marvel
cinematic universe has died at age 43
after a lengthy battle with colon cancer
the heartbreaking news was posted to
bozeman's personal twitter account on
the evening of august 28
2020 bozeman made his big screen debut
in 2008's the express the ernie davis
story
in that film bozeman played floyd little
a former college and professional
football star who was inducted into the
nfl hall of fame in 2010
from there bozeman went on to portray a
number of
iconic black pioneers in 2013 he
headlined 42 as jackie robinson
who broke baseball's color barrier and
became the first black man to play in
the major leagues
he also played soul legend james brown
and get on up
and starred as thurgood marshall the
first black supreme court justice
in marshall still it was bozeman's turn
as t'challa
king of wakanda that made him a
household name black panther which
debuted in 2018
was marvel's first movie with the solo
black lead
it was also a critical and financial hit
not only is black panther the highest
rated marvel movie on the review
aggregation
site rotten tomatoes but it scored seven
academy award nominations including one
for best picture
the first superhero movie to do so
bozeman's passing comes as a shock to
fans
most of whom didn't realize that bozeman
was sick
according to the official announcement
of bozeman's death the actor had been
battling cancer since 2016
the same year that he made his mcu debut
and captain america civil war
the reason why you didn't know despite
the toll that the disease and its
treatment took on bozeman's body
the star somehow found the strength to
film movies
attend red carpet premieres perform
charity work
and do interviews throughout his illness
that means that bozeman was ill
while he filmed black panther which
began production in early 2017
as well as his two subsequent marvel
movies the mega crossovers avengers
infinity war
and avengers in game he was also
undergoing surgery
and receiving chemotherapy treatment
while filming marshall
brian kirk's action thriller 21 bridges
and spike leads to five bloods
which is an early awards season
contender while bozeman was attached to
both black panther 2
which was originally scheduled to debut
on may 6 2022
and yasuke a movie about the first
african samurai
neither of those films started
production before bozeman's death
bozeman's last movie which is set to
debut on netflix sometime this year
will be ma rainey's black bottom which
was filmed in 2019
in that bozeman plays levy trumpeter for
female blues legend ma
rainey who's portrayed by viola davis ma
rainey's black
bottom is based on a stage play by
two-time pulitzer prize winner august
wilson
and is directed by tony award winner
george c wolfe
while bozeman kept his illness a secret
from the public bands became concerned
about bozeman's health in april 2020
when the black panther star posted a
video to instagram in which he announced
a collaboration between former legendary
entertainment ceo thomas tult
and surgical scrubs manufacturer figgs
on jackie robinson's traditional
april 15th date the partnership was
known as operation 42
and included a 4.2 million donation of
medical gear to the black communities
hit hardest by the coronavirus pandemic
that was remarkable news but it was
overshadowed by
bozeman's gaunt frame which had many
fans worried that something was wrong
some observers surmised that bozeman had
dropped weight for an upcoming role
others argued that he was just naturally
skinny in the midst of all the
speculation and comments on instagram
bozeman deleted the video from the main
feed of his social media indicating a
desire for privacy
now of course we know why in the hours
since bozeman's death was announced
many celebrities including bozeman's
former marvel co-stars brie larson
chris evans angela bassett and don
cheadle have taken to social media to
express their grief
our condolences go out to bozeman's
family and his loved ones during this
difficult time